glenn younkin scored a major upset in
virginia winning back the governor's
mansion for republicans on a
sophisticated campaign focused on
education parental rights and a return
to normal from the public health tyranny
of the past 600 days
he ran on a culture war conservative
campaign bucking the usual beltway gop
talking points
and from that shocking win
establishment republicans have learned
absolutely nothing i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knoll show
[Music]
before we get to virginia we've got some
breaking news that just came out and it
actually
centers around the daily wire and it
will have effects for basically
everybody in this country
the biden administration has just
formalized its vaccine mandate rule you
remember they announced it months ago
but that was basically a press release
we didn't know when it was going to go
into effect what the rule is going to be
they just dropped a 490 page rule
this will require
every company with more than 100
employees
to force their employees to take the
fouchy algae to to violate either their
religious con conscience possibly their
medical prunins their own personal
medical decisions or they're basically
threatening these businesses with
putting them out of business
the daily wire is suing the biden
administration we have just moments ago
filed a lawsuit uh this is gone in the
u.s court of appeals for the sixth
circuit
we are absolutely not going to comply i
will tell you that this legal fight that
we have just launched is going to be
extremely expensive
we we don't care we're willing to risk
it we've built a very powerful machine
here we've built it thanks to you we do
need your support now we need your
support now more than ever before if you
want to be in the fight
if you if this matters to you if you
don't think that the biden
administration should be able to use
this ridiculous workaround because they
basically admitted they don't have the
authority the authority to do this joe
biden said on the campaign trail he
wasn't going to be pushing vaccine
mandates because it was unpopular and
almost certainly unconstitutional so
what he did was this
bizarre byzantine work around through
the occupational safety and health
administration to get private businesses
to do their dirty work for them and they
know they're probably going to lose this
in court so they just want to force you
to all get it before the courts rule
against them this is a very very
difficult very expensive fight it is
thug tactics from a thug crooked
administration we're not going to take
it lying down but we we do need your
support now more than ever if you want
to be in the fight with us
i strongly suggest you do this is the
time to stand up people go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply jeremy boring has this to say
about it
again this is just coming out from the
press release the daily wire will not
comply with president biden's tyrannical
vaccine mandate we are suing the biden
administration to put a stop to their
gross overreach by president biden the
federal government social media and the
establishment media have conspired to
rob americans of their freedoms in the
name of public health they have broken
faith with the american people through
conflicting messaging false information
and by suppressing data and perspectives
with which they disagree
we are working with harmeet dillon you
may know hermit dylan very very
important very good lawyer in this
country she says quote the federal
government lacks the legal authority to
compel private employers to play the
role of vaccine or coveted police lack
the police power to force private
employees to undergo medical treatment
and may not ignore constitutional limits
on its ability to regulate every aspect
of our lives
she goes on the bind biden
administration's attempt to impose this
unprecedented and unlawful federal
medical mandate on the u.s workforce
without considering the public's views
as arbitrary capricious unsupported by
the evidence and would produce a
willfully ignorant rule willful
ignorance would seem to be
the
the theme for the biden administration
so right now i mean just this rule in g
will affect
80 million workers
or more very possibly more than that the
biden administration
is is
not even pushing a constitutionally
sound rule so much as they are
attempting to intimidate you to take
a
shot
an experimental shot you know a shot
that was just developed not that long
ago
even against your own judgment
for a virus that for the vast majority
of people does not pose a particularly
grave threat
this is it folks you know
there's there is an expression that i
really hate but it comes up a lot and
the squishes always bring it up they say
do you really want to die on this hill
oh come on you really want to die on
this hill this come on just give the
left whatever they want and then we'll
die on the next hill you know if you
don't stand up on a hill eventually you
run out of hills to fight on and then
it's over and then the battle's over and
the fight's over and so
we made it very clear from the moment
that the biden administration announced
they were going to do this
that we're not going to stand for it
we are not going to go down without a
fight
we're very fortunate that we've built a
strong platform here we have built a
strong platform with a strong voice that
is posing a real threat to the biden
administration and to the
liberal ruling class more broadly
and so we're going to use it
and it's not going to be easy and i'm i
understand there are going to be a lot
of companies that just kind of go along
with it they just don't want to have to
deal with it okay but we really believe
this is the fight this is the kind of
thing that we built this company for
okay and if we don't stand up here we're
not going to stand up for anything
so we're going to do that we're going to
put ourselves on the line and we're
going to lead the fight and we're going
to sue the biden administration and
we're going to take these jerks and
crooks and bullies and thugs to court
and we're going to take it as far as it
needs to go and we need
your support dailywire.com
subscribe code
do not comply do not let this moment
pass without fighting back
do not
tell your grandkids someday ah where was
i during that big fight when the medical
technocratic liberal tyranny finally
quashed the last little bit of freedom
and tradition we had in this country oh
well i was
cowering in a corner don't cower in a
quarter stand with us
fight it we appreciate your support
back to virginia my favorite comment
yesterday is from alejandra fernandez
who says my three-year-old is listening
to the podcast with me and he started
yelling no more blah blah blah after he
heard greta thundberg say it at the
climate protest and he keeps shouting it
i'm dead that is very meta that is a
very meta sophisticated
insightful young three-year-old boy of
yours because there is the
blah blah blah going on at the climate
conference and then there is literally
the blah blah blah that greta and her
followers were saying about the climate
conference
and then there is the blah blah blah
that your three-year-old is mocking it's
all a whole lot of blah blah blah coming
from the liberal establishment which is
probably why our society is crumbling
around us inflation is through the roof
and when inflation is going up it's a
good idea to start looking at physical
gold which is why i would strongly
recommend you check out acre acre lets
you start investing in physical gold for
as little as thirty dollars a month
before you call me a liar
before you tell me michael gold physical
gold costs more than thirty dollars i
know it costs more than thirty dollars i
know in the past it's been hard to
invest
in physical gold with the change in your
couch cushion acre has this ingenious
way you subscribe to their gold bars
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars acre will discreetly
ship the gold to your house they've also
got a new 100 a month subscription to a
5 gram gold bar
you don't need to come out of pocket all
at once to acquire meaningful gold over
time visit getacregold.com
knowles and start investing in physical
gold today make sure you go to that url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
getacregold.com knowles thank you acre
gold for supporting the show
republicans can't win for losing they
can't they can't learn anything
seems to me
major win in virginia
major major win on a very specific issue
education
on these real culture war type issues
the crazy racial theories being pushed
in schools the crazy sexual theories
being pushed in schools this lunatic
terry mcauliffe this thug saying parents
have no rights to raise their kids and
so here's the takeaway from the house
gop this is the house republican
establishment twitter account
said quote and this is posting an
article about glenn younkin's win
americans don't want socialism pass it
on
that race
had nothing to do with socialism
pass it on pass it
on i hate socialism i think socialism is
a wicked confederacy a pest a plague
that seeks to steal the very gospel
itself i don't think any christian can
subscribe even to moderate socialism i
am now just paraphrasing multiple popes
okay it's a very socialism is a really
really bad thing
not every bad thing
is socialism okay
it's like a square and a rectangle all
squares are rectangles not all
rectangles are squares
all of socialism is bad not all bad
things are socialism
what do you think terry mcauliffe is a
socialist
terry mcauliffe is a corrupt corporate
democrat he's a clinton apparatchik
he did not run on socialism the reason
glenn young can beat him is not because
of socialism
it's because of kooky racial theories
that the left was pushing it's because
of
psychotic
sexual theories that the left was
pushing it's because of justice and the
right to raise your kids
socialism no do you know why the reason
the establishment gop talks about
socialism
is because it's perfectly safe
it's total it's just it's economic
okay and it's you don't have to touch on
any of those culture war issues no one's
going to call you a racist or a sexist
or a phobe or whatever for opposing
socialism
but it completely misses the point it
completely misses what time it is which
is what we can expect
from the establishment republicans it's
pathetic though i don't know who wrote
that tweet
probably just some social media staffer
but this is the opinion of many in the
establishment who don't want to talk
about this stuff say oh if we talk about
critical race theory gosh maybe some
people might call us racist it won't be
legit it'll be tote but they might and
so
they call a sexist if we are phobic if
we talk about the trans issue let's not
talk about the trans bathrooms
let's not talk about the the curricula
that teach three-year-old johnny that he
can really be jane let's not talk about
the curricula now in schools across the
country and especially in virginia that
say that white people are born evil and
they're irredeemably evil and racist and
bigoted let's not let's just not touch
that even though that's like the only
thing that parents care about and the
only thing that motivated this young
victory let's just not uh
can we just please talk about socialism
no
socialism
is not
the point and it's not what we're
fighting against yes the horrible
economic policies are bad yes there are
a handful of democrats who call
themselves socialists and who openly
embrace it
but what we're fighting against is a
corrupt liberal establishment a
techno public health bureaucratic
crooked establishment that is pushing
insane
theories on people
and taking your kids away
focus on that they're going to try to
steal the yunkan victory
i'm not talking about the democrats i'm
talking about the establishment
republicans they're going to try to
steal it and say the way that we win in
2024 is by just running mitt romney 3.0
4.0 how many times does romney run at
this point the way that we win is just
by talking about cutting corporate taxes
that's how we're no it's not that's not
how young can won
that's not how we're going to win
contrary to popular cowardice the way
you're going to win the way you're going
to sway the suburban voters the suburban
moms
and by the way the way you're going to
sway racial minorities the ones that
you're going to to win the way you're
going to sway ordinary people
is not by talking about corporate tax
cuts it's going to be by talking about
our kids and what the left is trying to
do to our kids
and the racial and sexual division
they're pushing in this country and the
way they're upending not just all of our
american traditions and way of life but
our very understanding of nature itself
take a lesson take a lesson house gop
this is tough love i love you you know
we're we're in the same team and
everything but maybe pull out a notebook
and take a lesson here's here's a great
article i read is my favorite single
favorite article from the younkin
victory i drove in this morning smoking
a cigar
so i wanted i wanted to keep the
celebration going
it's like 30 degrees here
when you're driving around nashville i
don't care windows down smoking the
cigar
headline
is the daily wire hold on i've gotta
i've gotta read this in a different way
is the daily wire responsible for glenn
younkin's win
well what if we are
is the daily wire while there's plenty
of blame and credit to go around in any
election many believe the election came
down to one thing
a daily wire story so what if what if it
did
i wish i still had my cigar on me that's
how that's how cool i feel that's how
cool i think a lot of us conservatives
feel not not because we pulled some
dirty trick but because we
exposed a real problem
there were multiple real problems going
on in virginia specifically in loudoun
county and they were really big stories
that the new york times and the
washington post did not want to cover
about kids being victimized in schools
because of transgender policies or at
least the cover-up was because of
transgender policies about
the the kooky racial theories about all
of it
about terry mcauliffe saying parents
have no right to their kids education
and this is this is the my favorite part
at the end of the article oh they quote
me in the article that's great glad they
did
many this is the final line of the whole
piece many consider it unethical for
media outlets to function as an
apparatus of a political campaign
first of all the daily wire does not
function as a as a an apparatus of any
political campaign we do something that
the left-wing media don't do we actually
just go report the stories and tell the
truth
but if it is unethical for media outlets
to function as an apparatus of a
political campaign has someone
considered telling cnn
oh boy someone should tell the new york
times and the washington post and abc
nbc cbs msnbc
pbs npr
all of them
beyond the media how about facebook how
about twitter about google
which especially during 2020
intervened in in unprecedented ways
to suppress bad news for democrats and
to promote
bad news even if it was fake news for
republicans
yes i think there is look i don't want
daily wire to take all the credit for
this okay obviously glenn younkin ran a
really good really sophisticated
campaign chris ruffo for instance set
the stage on this education issue by
really exposing people to
critical race theory uh the native
virginian matt walsh you know went to
his school board in his state
commonwealth because he's a native
virginian
the parents are the ones the parents
really did the yeomans work they're the
ones who showed up to these school
boards right we covered that story but
it was the parents who were leading the
charge
it was the parents who made it a story
who who refused to let these guys
off the hook
and the libs could not be
angrier about it
there's a lesson here the lesson is not
that we need to keep running against
socialism yeah run against socialism
when socialism's on the ballot
but don't pretend that every bad thing
is socialism
we need to just keep running on tax cuts
and being really nice no no that's not
what happened that's not how yunkan won
you want the lesson for 2022 you want
the lesson for 2024 yeah talk about the
bad economy yeah talk about the crazy
coveted lockdowns yeah talk about all of
that
but focus on
things that matter to people i look i'd
like low taxes i do i don't i don't want
my taxes to go up i hate giving more
money to the government
but if you told me okay michael the
government's doing two things right now
they're gonna raise your taxes a little
bit and they're also gonna uh pervert
your child
it's not even close it's not i don't who
cares about the dollars and cents man
we're talking about
not only the the person that i you know
most interested in his future
but we're talking about the future of
the country
okay
focus on the things that matter
grow
aspine
republicans
they don't see it
maybe it's because there's all this
horrible blue light coming off of their
screens well if you want to block out
that blue light i strongly recommend you
check out blue blocks blue light hurts
your head okay i don't know how to put
it any more simply than that i didn't
really believe this a few years ago when
a friend of mine first informed me of
this i said oh no it's not a big deal
whatever and then when you start
blocking out that blue light
your eye strain goes way down you can
find yourself having less headaches less
blurred vision less of those dry watery
eyes it's amazing i almost never look at
a screen now with the blue light coming
out okay helps with anxiety depression
can help with low energy unlike other
types of blue light glasses blue blocks
are evidence-backed and made under
optics laboratory conditions in
australia blue blocks was created to
change all of this awful uh blue light
uh
damage and anxiety and all these
problems they use high quality lenses
for daytime nighttime and for color
therapy exactly in line with peer
reviewed academic literature go check it
out they got super cool frames go to
blueblocks.com
knowles right now use promo code knolls
at checkout to get 20 off enjoy free
shipping on orders over 115 bucks get
your energy back sleep better block out
the unhealthy effects of blue light with
blue blocks b l u b l o x dot com slash
knowles or just click the link below
make sure to use the code knowles to get
20
off your order and enjoy free shipping
on orders over 115 bucks blu
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com slash knowles for
twenty percent off today
jameel hill
is some uh left-wing blue check mark
she was responding to as the left is
wringing their hands and rending their
garments or gnashing their teeth over
the yunkan victory in virginia
someone another
left-wing blue check sahil kapoor goes
the story of tonight
mcauliffe is running a bit ahead of
biden among non-white voters in virginia
he's behind a few with white men but
he's getting clobbered by white women
white
women
and then jameel hill responds she has
white women
reporting for duty you they did this in
2016. i said the white women
they did this in 2018 especially with
the stacey with the white women didn't
show up for the democrats like they're
supposed to we own those white women
they didn't show up hate those white
women they're so oh they're so white uh
evil
and white
and they're ah they're just stopping
progress they're terrorists they're
insurrectionists they're a threat to our
democracy my
response to sahil kapoor
jameel hill all of the libs right now
who are focusing all of their ire on
white suburban women
keep it up oh please keep it up please
jameel
i want you to run on this i want all the
libs to run on this in 2022 and 2024.
vote for us we hate white women
vote for us or else you're a racist
vote for us you're an evil
insurrectionist you awful white people
please run on that please
please
didn't work out very well
for you this time in virginia did it
the racial
hatred that you are ginning up didn't
work out very well for you did it in a
blue state
so how's that going to work out in the
midterms how's that going to work out in
2012 i think that'll work out very well
for us because the idiot establishment
republicans they're they're going to run
the worst campaigns you can imagine they
are they're going to run
mark my words they're going to run on
socialism it's socialism okay so they're
going to try to lose it basically
they're not going to really but they're
going to do everything in their power to
clutch defeat from the jaws of victory
so we're relying on you jameel we're
relying on you democrats
please
make this about
pushing
vicious
racial theories and insane sexual
theories make this about taking our kids
away
please i beg you it's going to make
virginia look like child's play
and it comes down to education because
we view education in this narrow way of
your reading writing and arithmetic in
the classroom but education is so much
more
this is why since at least the 1960s the
left has been marching on all the
political offices marching on all the
centers of political power but they've
also been really marching on the english
department right
they've been marching on the classrooms
why did they make such a focus
about taking over the universities and
the high schools and the middle schools
and elementary schools
because they know that campuses and
classrooms are a crystal ball
they're a crystal ball they tell you
what your
country's going to look like in 20 years
right they focus on these impressionable
young minds because education is about
making citizens
it's about giving us a certain
understanding of our freedom so if they
can control that they're going to
control the country within a generation
that's what they have done
this is this is why critical race theory
the way that history is taught the way
really that everything is taught is such
a focus of theirs sunny hostin
who is one of the cackling hens on the
view sunny hostin
came out and and said the crt thing is
is really tough we gotta the democrats
need to defend crt and she's just sorry
if white kids feel a little bad about
learning about systemic racism
now the message is that white parents
are being ignored when they complain
that their children are uncomfortable
learning about racism that their white
children don't want to be uncomfortable
well let me tell you something black
kids around this country are stigmatized
and are made to feel uncomfortable every
single day and i don't think it's too
much to ask white parents to allow their
children to learn about the very real
history in this country that is still
very prevalent the systemic racism that
is still very prevalent in our country
what is so wrong with learning the real
history absolutely our country
[Applause]
so
this is the left's line they keep going
back and forth they keep saying crt
isn't real
or crt is only being taught at harvard
law school but it's not taught anywhere
else
and then when that doesn't work they say
actually crt is being taught everywhere
and it's really good and crt is just
about teaching the real history of
slavery
let me ask you something when you went
to school assuming you're not i know
this audience has a huge age gap you
know so there's or a huge age range so
there are some people who are 12 years
old listening to the show there's some
people who are 82 years old for the
people who are at the middle to older
end of that age range before critical
race theory came around
did you learn about slavery
did you learn about slavery in the
classroom i bet you did
did you learn about the civil war did
you learn about jim crow did you learn
about reconstruction did you learn about
civil rights movement yeah of course you
did
of course you did
learning about the history of slavery is
not the same as critical race theory
critical race theory is an analytical
framework developed by marx explicitly
by
marxists a derivation of critical theory
which i write about at great length in
my book speechless
that views america as intrinsically
unjust that views white supremacy
as the defining characteristic of
america that affects and pervades every
aspect of life
that views even our most basic economic
system as a product of white supremacy
which is why it all needs to be ripped
out root and branch that's critical race
theory that's very different than
learning about hey there was a slave
trade actually there was a slave trade
in africa that then western
colonists began to participate in and
that existed in america for a certain
period of time and actually much less
time than it did virtually anywhere else
in the world and actually outside of the
west slavery continues to exist
it predated slavery in in the west
where it was at least
coterminous
and it has existed long after slavery in
the west okay the problem is not kids
learning about
the truth about our history it's that
crt is teaching them falsehoods about
our history and it's teaching them
falsehoods about systemic racism
you remember ibrahim kendi the the mack
daddy hustler of of crt today and these
racial theories
even kendi had to delete his tweet
because he realized his tweet a couple
days ago undermined his entire thesis he
said there are a bunch of white kids who
lied about their race on their college
applications and pretended to be black
or native american and they had an
easier time getting into schools
and so he had to delete that because he
said oh crap i just totally undermined
my theory
there is there is systemic racism
there's legal racism in this country but
it's not the kind that sunny hosting
thinks it is
there is legal racism in this country
against
white people and asian people when they
apply to college and jobs it's called
affirmative action now you might say we
support affirmative action we support
that racial discrimination to make up
for whatever grievance there was in the
past
okay fine well then be honest about that
view but don't tell me that the legal
racism in this country
and racial discrimination is against
black and native american people it's
not
the legal racial discrimination is in
favor of black and native american and
other people and it is against white
people
and for whatever reason asian people
okay now
you might say well that's
that's just the legal racism but there's
a broader issue of systemic racism this
is what ibrahim kennedy tried to do when
he was doing damage control for his
whole theory falling apart he said well
but there are there are disparities of
outcomes between white people in america
and black people and hispanic people and
asian people and native american people
and so the only explanation for those
disparities of outcomes is that
white supremacy is is keeping all
keeping the black man and other people
down
that's not of course that's not the only
explanation here's a simple i mean this
is the most basic one that that i think
is pretty undeniable
uh fatherlessness
fatherlessness is a big predictor of
your outcomes in life
and right now 70 plus of black babies in
america are born out of wedlock
that's that would be one explanation
decisions in certain communities
culture
in certain communities
that would be another one
there are other factors too i'm not even
look i'm a conservative i'm not even
denying that history
has an impact on the present
i know some people try to pretend that
history doesn't matter at all even some
people on the right but i don't i'm not
saying that
what i am saying is this specific theory
that is being taught to kids of
pervasive white supremacy and legal
racism it's just
it's just bogus throw that away with the
easter bunny and the tooth fairy okay
that ain't
real and so we don't want our kids
learning lies in school we want them
learning the truth
we don't even want them learning
everything you know that that's kind of
the middle ground here is let's just
teach them everything let's open up the
curriculum let's just and they can pick
and they can choose no we just let's
just teach them how to think not what to
think no you got to teach people what to
think
if you don't tell people what to think
about the civil war began in 1860 that's
telling people what to think
you got to teach them facts abraham
lincoln said this he did this it's
teaching them what to think
and only then can they know how to think
about these broader issues and the
problem right now is the left is
teaching them what to think and the
things they're teaching them what to
think about are
false they're lies and so it's
perverting the way
that they come to think how to think
about the country
you know the daily wire is doing
everything possible
to bring you the truth every single day
especially with our recent foray into
investigative journalism the talent of
our journalists like luke roziak who is
being blamed and given credit for the
election in virginia
uh
this sort of stuff is uh really
important okay we watched that excellent
work the work of journalists like chris
ruffo affecting real change in the
virginia election which was a bloodbath
but investigative journalism is
expensive which is why so few media
companies do that work
this is also why we need your support
for as little as four bucks a month you
can help us continue exposing the truth
and reclaiming the narrative if you want
to join us in this fight go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code real
news to get your fix of real news today
we'll be right back with a whole lot
more
the left's racial grievance narrative is
false that's why we want it out of the
classroom not because we're afraid of
our history because it's just
patently absurd here's the
most preposterous example of it in
recent days colin kaepernick
you know the whiny former football
player who cashed in on racial grievance
and made a gazillion dollars doing it
colin kaepernick has a movie out that
opens up on him comparing
playing in the national football league
to being
a chattel slave
what they don't want you to understand
is what's being established
is a power dynamic
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
come on boys
look at that shape there look at this
mr farmer i got your bid 30. james 30 to
you 100 so
next one coming up best one we got
500
600.
look at this here
come on who wants this
700.
[Music]
so
okay so
you see all these football players
transformed into chattel slaves in the
antebellum south
and the nfl they're just like the slave
owners
slave auctions
brings up a pretty basic question
if the nfl is like a an antebellum slave
plantation
why has colin kaepernick spent the last
six seven years
begging them to take him back
if the nfl is slavery
then why is colin kaepernick been
begging to be a slave and whining when
they don't want to enslave him
did slaves in the antebellum south did
they have multi-million dollar contracts
did they spend their whole lives
training and just trying desperate to be
slaves on some plantation
i don't i don't think so
now what's funny colin kaepernick opens
up the movie and he's dressed like this
sort of clown version of malcolm x you
know like mark's observed
history repeats itself first first is
tragedy then his farce we're in the
farce portion of this sort of thing what
what colin kaepernick is observing
is that
in for slaves
and for football players
the the primary thing that matters is
your physical
health right you need for
for football players they're really it's
a primarily physical job there's a
little mental aspect to it too a little
bit of strategy but it's mostly you just
got to be big and strong and fast and
tough and well coordinated
and so i guess that's true
for physical laborers who were slaves i
guess that's true for
all sorts of physical laborers
colin kaepernick's very offended by this
athletics is about physical excellence
okay and unfortunately colin kaepernick
was not sufficiently excellent to
remain in the football league for very
long fine
not ever not everyone is very very few
people are if colin kaepernick is upset
that he he didn't pursue a more
intellectual field
you know it maybe he he he regrets being
having a physical career he wishes that
he were a paper pusher or something he
had a desk job well okay
then he should have spent his life
cultivating it cultivating his intellect
i guess but he certainly
he certainly hasn't done
that
there are many football players who are
pretty intellectual actually colin
kaepernick is not
not one of them
and these theories are having serious
ramifications for justice story came out
just the other day a group of forensic
anthropologists
are now arguing that trying to identify
the race the racial ancestry of
skeletons
is a terrible thing
and they are urging their peers to stop
doing the practice so a forensic
anthropologist
is someone
who looks at
a dead body
looks at skeletons
and
comes to conclusions about
the people that those skeletons were
right this is the height this was the
way this is the sex this is this is what
they looked like and the point of
forensic anthropologists is to give
people to give investigators all of that
information so that they can come to
certain conclusions about how they ended
up as skeletons
but the woke forensic anthropologists
say ancestry estimation
contributes to white supremacy
they say uh
they're they're using critical race
theory by the way they're invoking
critical race theory they say that they
they need to continue to situate and
contextualize our challenge to the use
of macromorphoscopic
traits
you know physical traits as well as
introduce critiques of craniometric and
dental morphological analysis head size
and teeth in ancestry estimation
don't you how dare you
come to racial conclusions about
skeletons
what they're upset about is that
different races of people look different
now
it's a fact
right
anyone with eyes can tell that different
races of people look different
this is important by the way if you're
trying to figure out who got murdered
who murdered who who did you know to
come to conclusions about criminal
justice but this is very bad because
then we're suggesting that
that then the races have some physical
differences
obviously
it's absurd but it gets to a real
difference in strategy here
we all want a flourishing just society
the left wants to get to a flourishing
just society
by denying reality
the right wants to get to a flourishing
and just society by dealing with reality
and grappling with reality and trying
not denying truths even if they're
politically incorrect and inconvenient
the left thinks the way that we're going
to deal with racial problems is by
denying that they exist is by denying
that on the one hand denying that race
exists at all
and then on the other hand exclusively
focusing on race but only when it's
conducive to their argument
that's not going to work
there is a one of the forensic
anthropologists san jose state
anthropologist elizabeth weiss said
quote if forensic anthropologists
abandon determining race then they are
going to be doing victims and their
families a big disservice and are
basically engaging in a dereliction of
duty right but what the woke people are
going to say is yeah but it's worth it
yeah it's too bad victims of crimes and
their families are unfortunately they're
not going to have justice but
at least then we can
keep our head in the sand and deny these
problems i don't think that's going to
help anybody i think that's not very
compassionate i think it's going to make
problems worse speaking of things to
pretend to be offended by
a nascar driver
is in a lot of trouble
there's this nascar driver
this nascar driver
uh came out
and he used a word you're not allowed to
say take a listen
well he drills my ass coming out of four
for no reason i mean where was he going
what was he gonna do spin me out he was
trying to do a harvick is what he was
trying to do
for what for second place to do what he
wasn't going to transfer through with
that
just freaking [ __ ] man so stupid i i
don't understand these guys
i should beat the [ __ ] out of them right
now is what i should do but that doesn't
do me any good either
and i've already had to pay enough fines
in my lifetime i'm sure i'll get another
one
spoken like a true nascar driver really
blunt really direct he didn't get in
trouble for saying i'm going to go beat
the s-h-i-t out of somebody no that's
fine
talking about he's going to go beat
somebody up that's totally fine but he
said a word you're not allowed to say he
said the word [ __ ]
that's
the r word some people are now calling
it
because he was saying this guy he did
something that was a little stupid a
little slow he shouldn't have done that
that was [ __ ] and you're not allowed
to say [ __ ] anymore
why not why not why can't we what does
[ __ ] mean [ __ ] means
slow
it's literally what the word means
but we're not allowed to say that
because some people
are a little slower right this is if
this is
fallen world we've all got defects we've
all got problems none of us is born
perfect
and so some some people
deal with that and that's a challenge in
their lives
what what we're seeing play out right
now is something called the euphemism
treadmill that's what the harvard
psychologist stephen pinker dubbed it
it's this idea that
certain
phrases and words will change over time
and political correctness has really
taken this to a sort of insane extreme
because the condition that they describe
is undesirable or difficult or painful
and so you just have to constantly paper
over with a new euphemism
you see this especially with a mental
deficiency
so over the years people with mental
handicaps have been called simple
simpletons idiots that was a that was a
clinical term [ __ ]
[ __ ]
handicapped handicapable what it's going
to keep it's going to keep changing
it's not going to help anybody
it's not going to fix anything to keep
changing all of those words but it's
going to keep
creating all of these euphemisms so that
we can ignore things
for the left
what you say
is much more important than what you do
the left around the west and in this
country as well
openly advocate killing [ __ ] people
in the womb
iceland bragged a couple of years ago
they said we've we've eliminated down
syndrome we've eradicated down syndrome
they didn't find a cure for down
syndrome they just kill all the down
syndrome babies in the womb
they will kill them in in this country
there are doctors who will
i guess most if not all of the doctors
will will say when you're when you're
pregnant they'll say okay we're going to
do a scan to see if your kid has and
they'll use whatever euphemism but
they'll what they're really saying is
we're going to scan to see if your kid's
[ __ ] and then if your kid's [ __ ]
you can kill him if you want
this is ghastly this is ghastly stuff so
the conservative response to this is one
i don't want you
scanning to see if my kid's [ __ ] i'm
going to love my kid no matter how my
kid turns out he's got six fingers and
12 toes and has some mental handicap and
looks i don't care i love my kid
and the left you know what the left is
going to say to that how dare you use
the word [ __ ] say you're going to
kill him what are you talking i'm using
a word to describe a reality
and i want to love all of these people
but you're saying no no don't say the
word don't describe the reality
but kill people that you don't like kill
people who you find undesirable
for though it's a very important lesson
about political correctness
what you and really just for the left's
program broadly what you say
is much more important than what you do
often what you say
is a way to excuse really evil heinous
actions this is very offensive this is
very wrong some left wingers are waking
up to this by the way
van jones who is a left winger he goes
on cnn all the time i actually kind of
get a kick out of van jones especially
because he got caught on a hidden camera
one time admitting early on in the the
trump presidency admitting that the
russia hoax was a hoax and it was a
nothing burger and he had to kind of
walk it back because he
he didn't mean to say that publicly
van jones just came out reacting to what
happened in virginia
and he said he fears hey listen fellow
democrats i'm just putting this out
there
i think we might be coming off as a
little annoying and a little out of
touch
i think that the democrats are coming
across in ways that we don't recognize
that are annoying and offensive
and seem out of touch in ways that i
don't think show up in our feeds when
we're looking at our kind of echo
chamber and i think this is a message
here
better late than never van
you you're on a mission of mercy to your
fellow democrats by telling them this
because yes
they are coming off as annoying
and defensive
and extremely out of touch
and in a way it's not their fault
i mean it is you know they they did this
they're responsible for their actions
but it's an easy trap to fall into
they are in their own echo chamber
not in the same way that we talk about
political polarization and everyone
because of social media is only hearing
from people they agree with and no it's
because of a much bigger social problem
the left controls everything
right so
if you're a right winger in this country
no matter what kind of little tiny
bubble you're in and you only go to
dailywire.com ever and you don't look at
any other way and you only talk to
republicans even still
you will have to be exposed to left-wing
views
there's no way around it
it's like a fish in water okay it's just
all around
it's like the air that we breathe
liberalism leftism progressivism it's
all there and so you look at a billboard
you see it
you you look at a movie preview you see
it you talk to your friends and family
you see it
okay and you know what their arguments
are
and
you look on big tech i mean you look at
you look in the schools you look
everywhere you see it
the left does not have that
misfortune but really that advantage
at a deeper level that advantage because
the left has no clue
what we think
and there have been social scientific
surveys to back up this idea they have
no clue they have no clue how they come
across
this is why they're always so shocked
when they lose that's why they don't
really believe it when they lose
sometimes we don't believe it when we
lose an election like in 2020 when they
changed all the election rules right
before the election and then a bunch of
ballots came in at three in the morning
and okay i think we had some reason to
question it but generally when we lose
we accept it you know 2012 we lost you
know 2008 we lost the left doesn't do
that they're still fighting the 2000
election the 2018 gubernatorial election
the 2016 presidential election you're
still going to be fighting this thing in
virginia they
don't
it it just does not compute to them
because they are almost never exposed
to what about half the country thinks
van jones referred to the annoying out
of touch
offensive democrats on on cnn
one of them one of the most prominent
ones is his colleague on cnn brian
stelter
brian stelter just went on a nine minute
monologue
about
what donald trump could possibly do over
the next couple of years
i i'm not going to subject you to all of
it we don't have time on the show to get
to get to all of this i am going to
punch in though
uh right around the six and a half
minute mark okay where he's just
whipping himself up into a frenzy of
what donald trump is going to do if we
don't stop him
common ground erodes largely because
there's no common media ground anymore
it's as if america has been swallowed up
by q anon conspiracy theories
freedom of expression feels
trampled muffled and remember as all of
this is happening as democracy
deteriorates in 2024 trump's enablers
claim they are the ones protecting
democracy
they think or at least they pretend that
they are upholding the declaration of
independence they cloak their autocratic
actions in the language of the founding
fathers they claim to be the most
patriotic americans of them all and this
narrative is advanced 24 hours a day by
the abc the apps the broadcasters and
the commentators who justify stomping
all over the constitution as an attempt
to save it the country is on pins and
needles
landlords board up downtown windows
maybe looting starts shooting starts
i'm not saying that all this will happen
but i'm saying it could
we know it could happen because it has
all happened before almost everything i
have described has already happened
it has brian you're right it has already
happened in one form or another
but i think you're getting the source of
that problem a little wrong i think you
might be engaging in what psychologists
call projection
there there's no
neutral
you know middle ground media landscape
anymore
there are lies that are being pervaded
that are pervading the culture
business owners are boarding up their
windows there's political violence in
the streets brian stelter's pretending
this could come from republicans
it did come from democrats on the media
front for the past 50 years
on the violence front for 2020 from blm
from antifa not from trump the so-called
deadly insurrection didn't kill anybody
they pretended that the lying media said
that it killed officer brian sicknick it
turned out that was a lie new york times
and washington post had to retract it
all of that violence came from
the left he doesn't see it
he says we're not we can't even trust
each other anymore we delegitimize the
opposition in trump's future america
in the rights media echo chamber growing
ever more extreme the words democrats
and criminals are conflated constantly
so the other side loses legitimacy bit
by bit by bit
the gop media is on board with this
they're on board with the power grab at
all costs
driven by fear of a changing country
fear propelled by the likes of tucker
carlson and laura ingram who bring up
things like caravans right at key
moments during the election and all of
this in 2022 helps the gop regain
control of the house
members of the january 6th sedition
caucus are now in control of the body
that completes the electoral college
process
now some democrats fret about what's
going to happen in 2024. they worry if
the insurrectionists will have the upper
hand next time but remember in trump
world up is down and day is night and
trump keeps saying the insurrection was
biden's election
you know in this horrible scary future
the republicans are going to
delegitimize their opposition and say
that they have no right to participate
in the democracy
and they're all insurrectionists
brian do you listen to yourself
do you listen he doesn't listen to
himself
every
single thing
that he is accusing republicans of doing
and and really predicting that
republicans will do in the future
he himself is doing
to his political opponents
right now and he's not even aware of it
jennifer rubin the former pretend
conservative columnist now she
basically admits she's a liberal
columnist at the washington post she
tweeted out quote i realize critics say
dems have gone too far left but that
does not compute
the agenda is very popular they simply
haven't gotten over the finish line yet
here it is here it is folks
i i'm good i don't think she's being
cynical here i think she really believes
this i think the left really believes
this
of course the agenda's popular if
something just went wrong
because the agenda must be popular
because it is their agenda and it's
progressive and they see the future and
they know the way to utopia and it's
going to be great
and everyone knows it
so the only way
that they can lose an election
is if something went wrong there was a
problem of of understanding or
interpretation
or if there was fraud this is why they
can't concede elections sometimes
republicans don't want to concede
elections especially when there's a
when they upend all the rules right
beforehand but much more often it's the
left that won't concede the elections
because they can't because they have to
win
the agenda by definition their agenda
must be popular no matter what the
parents in loudoun counties say
some smart republicans are are seeing
what this the situation for what it is
someone
someone down there in florida like
governor ron desantis who is now
embracing
this popular revolt not just against one
party but really against kind of ruling
class
he's embracing let's go brandon
when you look at the biden the brandon
administration in terms of what they're
doing
do you know how that started like it was
and like you know you have the media
their hand ringing over this um
but you know it was at a nascar race and
they're doing an interview with the
driver i guess his name was brandon
and the crowd starts chanting very
colorful language about
joe biden and it was obvious that that
they were doing and um you know it is
what it is first of all they said way
worse about trump for four years we know
that um
but so they're chanting this and so you
have a reporter
from nbc who knows that's what they're
saying and she's trying to cover for
biden so she says yeah they're chanting
let's go brandon
and that was a lie
and it was a lot and so the this chant i
think has taken on a life of its own
because
it exposes
uh the dishonesty of these corporate
reporters and what they do every day to
try to lie this is what
desantis is getting that a lot of people
don't get
let's go brandon is not primarily about
joe biden they say f joe biden too but
it's not the let's go brandon chant is
not primarily making fun of biden it's
making fun of the media because the
media lied about the f joe biden chant
and so now we're turning our ire on the
media and on the whole
establishment and it's not the socialist
policies of job it's not it's about this
whole blob it's this ugly thing where
joe biden is a part of it but it's much
much bigger than that and that's why
it's bringing in many more people than
just your average regular rock ribbed
republican learn
the lessons people
learn the lessons establishment
republicans this is a big opportunity
there is a big popular uprising right
now
are we going to take that into 2022 and
2024 and actually do something and
change the situation in this country for
the better are we going to stay mired in
the past i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show